the taliban seem to be everywhere
mingling with shoppers controlling who
goes where and what women wear
many told us they're venturing out for
the first time since the taliban took
control and we saw no female who wasn't
covered up as the taliban want even if
it's not a decree
it's an islamic society and there is no
need to tell them to wear a hijab
we haven't had to ask them everyone is
obeying that now
behind the bustle and semblance of
normality there's a lot of uncertainty
and fear and it takes bravery to talk to
a western crew in these times
[Music]
[Music]
as we walk through the market a young
woman has approached one of our team off
camera she's one of thousands left
behind when the foreign troops were
pulled out
she's too scared to talk openly to us
but travels with her sister to where
we're staying
they show us the taliban death threats
sent to their mother who's a school
principal our main aim and work is to
kill old students
and teachers and the principal
she's not the only one to get one most
of the extended family worked for the
americans and other age groups like care
which has a british base and that means
their taliban targets
they have pictures with a former us
first lady and others with their british
military partners the younger sister was
one day off finishing her thesis when
the taliban took control ending her
degree hopes and changing her life
want me because i'm a girl i don't have
the right to come out of my home without
a mail
why because this is the unequality
i don't have the same right as a boy
i'm nothing for them
the family seemed to qualify for asylum
status in multiple countries yet none
have answered their calls for help
why i even worked for you is
that in such kind of situations they are
not responsible they are not responding
yes
they are not hearing us
it's a waste of my work experience all
those years waste of efforts waste of
struggle waste of everything actually
right now
i even have i even carry some kind of
hate in my heart for them
we go to see a female activist who's a
mother we're calling her fatima for her
safety we met her before the taliban
took control she was running for her
life then she's still running
fatima and her family were cleared for
evacuation by the british military but
before she could get there the suicide
bomb detonated killing nearly 200
including 13 u.s service personnel
she's relying on the kindness of friends
now trying to keep one step ahead of the
taliban who vowed to kill her and her
young children
i prefer to die at sea at the hands of
human traffickers trying to escape here
then be killed by the taliban she tells
us but i'm a prisoner here right now
the taliban insist women do have
freedoms but so far the taliban version
of female freedom looks worryingly
restrictive
alex crawford sky news kabul